what's going on guys this is rob and
honestly i was supposed to wait until
next week to cover this but i'm not
going to i'm going to go ahead and cover
it now
[Laughter]
because the god of hammers is just so
good what it looks like is there will be
like an epilogue to this so we'll cover
that epilogue once it's released
assuming it hasn't come out already i'll
have to double check and make sure uh
but picking up off the last video that
we did this is now thor with the full
totality of the odin force now here's
one thing that i want to specify here
and it's one of the things that donnie
case has established here that the odin
force in its full totality its
completion cannot be fully handed over
to thor until odin has completely passed
on which means that there's only ever
been one time when thor had this level
of the odin force and that was when he
was rune king thor that seems to be the
only time or at least there were a
couple things that added as a caveat to
that like powered by the nornstones and
so on and so forth but thor's
ridiculously overpowered here right it's
the most powerful version of thor that
we've seen with the exception of rune
king thor and presumably when he had the
power cosmic although we're not entirely
sure i don't think marvel's ever really
scaled the power cosmic versus the odin
force although i think it just stands to
reason through common sense at least for
those of us who have read comics that
the the odin force is not nearly as
powerful as the the power cosmic right
so you just kind of roll with that and
accept it but ultimately what ends up
happening is that in this conflict thor
actually ends up summoning hofan from
sith right he'll fund basically being
the sword of heimdall that has now been
passed to sif following heimdall's death
and so the cool thing about this is that
when with him having that and using the
odin force one of the things that sif
says is you can't be reckless with this
power this power you have you can't just
use it willy-nilly this is not like
years gone by where you basically have
you know you can just face off against a
threat seemingly forever if you exhaust
too much of the odin force you'll fall
into the odin's sleep even if that
happens in the middle of a battle right
you could literally be fighting this
person and then just pass out and if
that happens they'll destroy you because
i can't keep you protected from this
storm it's just way too powerful but the
response of thor is i don't care give me
your sword and in turn the sword is
handed to thor who uses it to open the
bifrost and then teleport uh the the
really the sentience of the hammer this
storm directly to the forge where uh
where mjolnir was made and it's cool
because he snatches the hammer back from
it and it's just like do you recognize
this place like do you know this place
and initially the the the storm is kind
of like not right off the bat and thor
is like this is a forge right this is
where you were born mjolnir and this is
where you will be destroyed this is
where you will be ended and so what ends
up happening here and this is a crazy
thing thor quite literally reignites the
forge and in doing so right it's like
the heat of a billion suns which is
enough to seemingly overpower the uh the
storm itself and then in doing so with
when it initially tries to take the
hammer back and use it again thor takes
the hammer back a second time and at
that point thor starts smashing the
hammer on on the forge now this is
absolutely insane because one of the
things to keep in mind when it comes to
the thor mythos hit you know a situation
where he quite readily starts destroying
his own hammer that's not something that
you would normally see and in fact thor
prizes the hammer above all else and his
use of the hammer is only a relatively
recent thing in the lifespan of thor for
those of you guys who never read jason
aaron's run one of the things that was
established in thor god of thunder is
that for years he was never able to lift
mjolnir the enchantment was put on the
hammer and the hammer was basically left
there by odin so that when thor was
ready he could pick it up and he could
wield it but for quite some time in his
life he wasn't really able to he was
never really able to wield a hammer the
only thing that he really had at his
disposal was yarn bjorn which is why if
you go when you read uh rick remembers
uncanny avengers there's a point where
he fights apocalypse in the past but he
can't use his own hammer he ends up
having to use a battle axe that's
magically enchanted to destroy celestial
armor and that's how one yarn bjorn
becomes as powerful as it is and two how
it is that he's able to overpower
apocalypse and so this hammer is a core
part of thor's life right it's as much a
part of his own body as his beating
heart and so destroying it is not
something that he readily does but in
going through and ripping this hammer
apart obliterating this hammer what it
seems to do is destroy the essence of
the storm now this is where things get a
little murky and this is something that
may very well be addressed in the in the
epilogue if it's ever addressed by
donnie cates at all although knowing
donnie cates there's a couple
conclusions we can draw here the first
is that the storm existed outside of the
hammer right that it was literally
encased inside the hammer at some point
in time by odin and so destroying the
hammer doesn't seem like it would be
enough to destroy the storm the storm
would just dissipate and go back out
into the universe and then continue its
quest of death and destruction the other
part other conclusion that we can draw
from this is the fact that because the
the storm had been imbued to the hammer
for so long that it is part and parcel
to the hammer so if the hammer is
destroyed the storm dies with it it
could also be that simply just the power
of the sun just melts this thing and
that's kind of been a cornerstone of the
thor mythos really since jason aaron's
run that the power of the sun is so
extreme that if someone is encased in it
they could basically be obliterated by
it i mean quite literally that's what
happened with man gog that man gog's
physical form was destroyed in the sun
and that its spiritual essence lived on
hence the reason why it bonded itself to
the hammer right why it bonded itself to
the storm but it's kind of a crazy thing
because even when you look at that like
a star is not really powerful enough to
destroy a being of sufficient power
right it's like throwing a beach ball at
thanos this really wouldn't make any
sense right and so it really can kind of
go either way which is why i say i don't
think we've heard the last of this i
don't i don't think we've seen the last
of this storm or any of this stuff but
what we do end up getting is that in the
aftermath of this because it required
the totality of the odin force to
destroy this hammer thor ultimately
passes out and then when he wakes up
four months have passed now again that's
the nature of the odin's sleeve that the
open sleeve kind of changes depending on
who's writing the story so there are
times when the odin's sleep has lasted
almost a year and there are times when
it's lasted like a month but in effect
all this is is just thor recharging
that's really all it is it's him
recharging the power of the odin force
because remember it's part and parcel to
him now thor is in the in possession of
the totality of the odin force that
seems to be the case and so as he begins
to wake up one of the things that he
says is that he feels like he heard the
voice of odin while he was in the odin's
sleep and then ultimately ends up you
know waking up and realizing that
angela's there and freya is there and
loki's there right angela being the
sister of thor right you know from uh
from the realm of heaven but nonetheless
it's kind of a funny thing because what
he's told there is that in the time that
he's been gone a funeral has not been
held for odin and the reason why is
because thor should be the one to lead
that funeral so it's very ceremonial and
honestly it's very very appropriate but
at the end of the day angela's like you
know we'll hold a ceremony right but
there's there's no rush there was
nothing to bury right there's no body or
anything like that like odin is totally
gone right his essence has been
dispersed you are now in possession of
the odin force and that's basically it
and so in turn they're all you know you
have like loki and yeah freya and it's
kind of like i mean look you know you
need to rest you need to to let your
energies recover and the response of
angela is he doesn't need any of that
like we all know what he needs right he
does not need to rest he doesn't need
any grape juice right he doesn't need
prune juice he doesn't need the golden
girls what thor needs is exactly what
we've done for him and so ultimately she
says get dressed meet me in the armory
and so what ends up happening is once
thor gets there it's this really really
amazing moment when thor gets to the
armory he finds the hammer has been
restored and it was restored by the
angels of heaven now i want to offer a
bit of an explanation here a lot of you
guys who have been reading thor for a
long time you guys know or at least
already know this but for the people who
are new here i want to make sense of
like the realm of heaven and angela and
all that stuff right so the idea here is
that the character of angela was
originally part of the spawn mythos out
in image comics for the longest time but
what ended up happening is through a
series of rights ownerships and all
kinds of stuff the character of angela
ended up coming over to marvel because
the guy who created her came over to
marvel and so that basically meant that
all the things he created came with him
because when it comes to like
independent creators their own creations
are their own product they belong
directly to them and not anybody else
which is one of the reasons why you see
a lot of major comic book creators write
indie comics because they maintain total
ownership but the way that marvel played
this out is they said that angela was
actually from a realm called heaven and
it was the 10th realm instead of it
being the nine realms but due to a
conflict that had been held at a
previous point in time and what was
basically a kind of armistice so to
speak not really even a treaty just
essentially a ceasefire that the tenth
realm was cut off from the nine realms
and it was allowed to just kind of live
out there and do its own thing but all
that was covered in original sin and so
when this revelation came to pass you
ended up learning there was this great
big huge realm out there right and it
was called heaven and it had all these
angels and all these people in it that
nobody knew about and that angela is
actually the sister of thor and so
that's what angela's talking about when
she says like the angels of heaven were
able to reassemble this thing it's not
perfect it's not to its original state
but we did what we could and so there's
this really amazing moment because
remember thor and angela haven't always
seen eye to eye and there's always been
a bit of a conflict there between the
two of them but this is a massively
respectful thing that angela and the
angels of heaven had done here something
they didn't even really have to do
because they don't view odin the same
way that they view thor right they see
thor is somebody entirely different and
in a lot of ways far more honorable than
odin was and that's why angela says like
i told you i would clean up your mess if
i had to regardless of what that mess
happened to be so consider it cleaned up
and initially he's like i know it's just
a hammer like i know that's that's it
like it doesn't have the power that it
had before it's not mjolnir as it's
always been which is a very important
thing right it's not milner the way that
it's been before which means that thor
could use this and in some situations it
would be stronger whereas in other
situations it could be weaker where it
would have been stronger so things
aren't necessarily the same it's really
a way for marvel to kind of rework the
nature of the hammer and under what
conditions are the most conductful to
use it and so what ends up happening
here is thor's like i know there's no
power here but at the end of the day you
know it's i'm okay with that and that's
when angela says well i mean maybe but
honestly i think it just depends on who
wields it don't you and so ultimately
thor you know where he turns around
angela's gone and he's like okay and
then he actually prays to odin and he
says father i know somewhere you can
hear my prayer i am just so lost i can't
see the path that you've laid out before
me and then he hears this voice that
says keep your eyes open boy and then it
goes to the hammer and it says a king
cannot rule from his knees and so in
essence what it looks like here and i
could be wrong we won't know until we
get to the epilogue but what it looks
like here is the spirit of odin if you
can call it that odin without the odin
force i don't really know what that is
but the spirit of odin is now encased
inside the hammer whether that's true i
don't know but if if that is the case
this is a wholly different situation now
and no idea where in the world this even
goes i have no clue but having said that
i absolutely love this god this is the
this was a ridiculously good thor story
i love it when like writers come along
and shift things up change things around
it keeps it from growing stale right it
keeps it from getting boring right
because after a while i was like well
here comes thor with me on there
whatever but like i love that this is
being changed up i find it absolutely
awesome and refreshing so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end uh we'll probably make a full
story out of this don't worry thank you
all for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace